most people do not realize the degree to
which the choices that they're making
are being influenced by people that
they're not even aware of and how when
you're going to the search results on
google or to your newsfeed on Instagram
or Facebook they're not picking things
that you like so much as they're picking
things that they believe they can
monetize and this is a really important
distinction because what they're doing
is they're creating a date of who do
doctoral stunts it's a great phrase
Tristana came up with data voodoo doll
they're gathering data we think we give
them a little data the thing you have to
understand is that data that we're
giving them that's a vanishingly small
percentage of what they have because in
real life we touch electronic systems
all over the place
every time we use a credit card every
time we go to the bank any medical thing
generates a digital record our phone
tracks where we are in real time any
time we send an email on or to a gmail
or Microsoft email account when we use a
shared online application like Google
Docs or office 365 there's a digital
trail from all these things and all of
that data is available to Google
Microsoft Facebook Amazon and they
create the state of voodoo doll and
every time you do a search every time
you look at your newsfeed you have to in
your head realize oh my god
these guys are using that data voodoo
doll to manipulate the choices that are
available
my facebook reach is declining by the
second after I've had professor David
Carol first and now Roger McNamee
joining me on modern wisdom
Roger welcome to the show it is such a
pleasure to be here Chris really excited
to have you on today very timely with
the release of the great hack on Netflix
and this resurgence of interest in
Facebook in Cambridge analytic can you
tell the listeners who don't know who
you are a little bit back sure about
yourself please so I first came to
Silicon Valley in 1982 as an investment
analyst right before the personal
computer industry began and I was lucky
enough to be part of the most important
firms investing first in public tech
stocks in the 80s then part of kleiner
perkins which was became the biggest
venture capital firm in Silicon Valley
during the 90s the heyday of the
internet I was in their office the day
that Marc Andreessen brought in the idea
that became Netscape the day that Jeff
Bezos brought in the idea that became
Amazon the day that Larry and Sergey
brought in Google I started a firm with
Bono in 2003 called elevation and in
2006 a 22 year old entrepreneur came
into my office with a crisis his name
was Mark Zuckerberg
I helped him navigate the crisis and for
a period of three years thereafter was
one of his advisors and that is the
context for my conversation with you
here today
that from 2006 to approximately 2016 I
was a huge fan of Facebook and then it's
beginning of 2016 I started to see
things going wrong on Facebook which
really violated my sense of what the
company was about
I thought Facebook was a force for good
and it began in the u.s. presidential
primaries in the Democratic Party in
2016
it then included issues related to black
lives matter a protest group in the
United States and then brexit happened
in June of 2016 and if that was the
point at which I realized that the same
algorithms the same business model
that makes Facebook so great for
marketers those same tools could be
manipulated and used to undermine
democracy and at that point I started to
realize I needed to do something I
started looking for allies and couldn't
find any I was finally able to persuade
a tech blog to let me write an opinion
piece about this in September of 2016
and while I was writing it more news
came out civil rights violations on
Facebook and then our intelligence
agencies said the Russians were trying
to interfere in the u.s. election so I
sent the draft of the opinion piece to
Mark Zuckerberg and Sheryl Sandberg my
friends to warn them I thought something
was really catastrophic ly wrong with
the product and they were not
particularly supportive actually I think
they they they treated it like a public
relations problem into the public
relations problem was me so they tried
to make it go away and in the process
they handed me off to one of their
colleagues a guy I knew really well that
I was very friendly with and we spent
three months and I after the u.s.
presidential election I go to them guys
you have got to do what Johnson &
Johnson the pharmaceutical firm did when
somebody put poison in bottles of
Tylenol the analgesic in drug stores all
over the city of Chicago killed a bunch
of people and the CEO of Johnson &
Johnson didn't wait for the government
didn't wait for anybody to come they
withdrew every bottle of Tylenol from
every retail shelf in America and didn't
put it back until they had invented
tamper proof packaging and I thought
that's the right way to handle a crisis
like this if you have played a role in
harming the civil rights of people if
you've played a role potentially in
undermining democracy in the United
Kingdom in the United States you have
got to throw yourself on the mercy of
the court the same way that Johnson
Johnson did and I spent three months
pleading with them please do this and
they would have none of it and finally
in February of 2017 I realize
was hopeless and I was faced with one of
those choices a moral choice that
hopefully you never have to come across
but in my case I did where I had
officially retired from the investment
business I could just walk away and say
it was somebody else's problem but I
didn't for whatever reason I realized my
fingerprints are on this thing I'd
played a role I wasn't a huge part of it
but I was part of it and I'd done two
things I'd helped stuck keep the company
independent 2006 and I'd helped to bring
Sheryl Sandberg into the company and
those two things had made a big
difference and I thought to myself if
I'm not willing to just stand up and do
something about this I'm not willing to
do stand up about anything and so I
became an activist and I didn't know
what that meant at the beginning
honestly the goal was really simple just
make people aware the problem and I met
a young man named Tristan Harris who was
coming out of Google and Tristan had
been on the u.s. news program 60 minutes
and he had given about a ten minute
presentation on something he called
brain hacking which is the use of
persuasive technology on smart phones by
internet platforms and how you can
manipulate people's attention and a
light bulb went off in my head and I
just realized that's how the brexit
thing and the u.s. election things had
happened and so the two of us joined
forces and set out to try to make the
world aware of this thing and the first
thing we did we caught a miracle in a
bottle I mean was just unbelievable two
weeks after we joined forces was the TED
conference in Vancouver Canada
Ted is well you know it's ground zero
for TED Talks right I mean this 1,500
technology and entertainment design
people all in one room were thinking
we'll get Tristan to do his brain
hacking thing there everybody will know
we'll get 1,500 business cards we'll be
all done our job will be over so we go
to tent this a miracle occurs and
somebody gets Tristan on the docket I'm
ten days notice and keep in mind
normally TED talks people prepare them
for six months Tristan has got ten days
he goes there he just shoots the light
out it was just amazing he was fantastic
and we're going around to collect cars
we got two business cards afterwards and
no follow-up at all
it was completely hopeless we're just
despondent and then another miracle
occurs and I get connected to a guy in
Washington who works for Senator Mark
Warner who is the vice chair of the
Senate Committee on intelligence which
is was at that time the only committee
at Congress where the two parties were
working together and they were the
natural place to look at Russian
interference and potentially to help us
protect the 2018 and 2020 letters and
that began our interaction of Washington
and so we go there we have very
successful meetings with him and with
senator Elizabeth Warren who was very
focused on on the competition antitrust
issues and that got us started we wind
up playing a role in causing the
hearings to take place in the fall of
2017 in preparing Congress for those
hearing teaching everybody what they
needed to know about Facebook and
Twitter and to a lesser extent Google
they kind of understood Google and I've
basically been doing this full-time
24 hours a day ever since and I've
written a book called sucked waking up
to the facebook catastrophe which has
been a platform for activism I continue
to go to Washington all the time I
continue to deal with folks and press
and my job is really simple there is a
very very scary thing going on and most
of us have no idea I mean we think we're
giving up a little personal data for a
service we love right it could be
YouTube it could be Facebook it could be
Instagram it could be you know anyone if
it does something we have no idea that
that's not what's going on at all that
these guys are building versions of the
matrix or of Minority Report and they're
not doing it because they're bad guys
they're doing because they're engineers
and it's a really interesting
engineering thing can you use massive
data gathering
and algorithms to make the world more
efficient that seems like a lot of will
go the problem of it is that if you
convert all human experience into data
if you process it with machine learning
if you then use it to make the world
more efficient something's gotta give
in fact new things have to give one of
them is democracy and the other one is
freewill and individual choice and my
attitude on this is real simple
maybe people are okay with that but they
don't know that's what's going on and we
need to have a conversation about in
order for conversation to happen
somebody's got to tell him what's really
going on and I'm one of the people who
has decided to devote my life to doing
that we are big fans of Tristan Harris
on the show I first heard him on Sam
Harris just over a year ago year and a
half ago and we went down that rabbit
hole big style after that I spoke to
highway the CEO of the light phone have
you heard of that yeah yeah of course
yep spoke to Kai very interesting guy so
we've been the listeners will be
familiar I think with tech reduction and
the ice to the bottom of the brainstem a
little yeah but it's it's really
important but the think Chris to keep in
mind is we keep learning new things and
Tristan and I spent last weekend not
this past weekend but the one before
together and we were comparing notes
about how far we had come because when
we got together we thought that the
addiction hypothesis that Tristan had
come up with the one that underlies the
like phone that underlies all this other
things was the root cause of the problem
but earlier this year a professor from
Harvard Business School names Shoshanna
subha published a book called the age of
surveillance captain it actually came
out in Europe in the fall of last year
but it came out in the States in January
and it changed our lives
because Shoshanna has been studying
Google for more than a decade and she
spent roughly a decade writing this book
and it is the most important work of
economics sociology in my lifetime and
again that's my opinion but I really
feel strongly about this that this book
is to the 21st century what Adam Smith's
The Wealth of Nations was to the 18th
and 19th I mean it describes an economic
system that is dominating the world but
about which people are completed and
aware and it names everything it
describes how it works and the important
thing to understand is the reason that
addiction exists is because of the
incentives of this surveillance
capitalism which is about gathering all
the possible data converting all human
experience into data and then using it
to make the world more efficient and you
sit there and say again is there
anything wrong with that and I go it's
not for me to say but most people do not
realize the degree to which the choices
that they're making are being influenced
by people that they're not even aware of
and how when you're going to the search
results on Google or to your newsfeed on
Instagram or Facebook that they're not
picking things that you like so much as
they're picking things that they believe
they can monetize and this is a really
important distinction because what's
what they're doing is they're creating a
date of who do doctoral stunts it's a
great phrase Tristana came up with data
voodoo doll they're gathering data we
think we give them a little data the
thing you have to understand is that
data that we're giving them
that's a vanishingly small percentage
with data because in real life we touch
electronic systems all over the place
every time we use a credit card every
time we go to the bank if we want to buy
a home there's a credit rating score any
medical thing generates a digital record
our phone tracks where we are in real
time anytime we have an affinity card
from a grocery store any kind of air
all that data is captured anytime we
sent an email on or to a gmail or
Microsoft email account when we use a
shared online application like Google
Docs or office 365 there's a digital
trail from all these things and all of
that data is available to Google
Microsoft Facebook and listen now
obviously Microsoft and Google do not
solve their data they just keep theirs
but they buy the stuff from everybody
else Facebook does the same thing and
they create this data food at all and
every time you do a search every time
you look at your newsfeed you have to in
your head realize oh my god these guys
are using that data voodoo doll' to
manipulate the choices that are
available to me they know my income they
know where I work they know how long I
commute they know the composition of my
family right they know how I spend money
where I spend money and they're not
using that to make my life better
they're using that to make money and
again we may be ok with that but we
ought to have a conversation about
what's really going on because it's in
my thought experiment that I want to
give to everybody who's listening right
now is just imagine this what if I'm
right what do you wish you what will you
wish you had done if it turns out I'm
right because the thing about Shoshanna
tsubasa book is it is brilliantly
researched it is like 500 pages of text
and 200 pages of footnotes I mean the
woman is I mean she deserves the Nobel
Prize in Economics and I've never met
anyone like her as impressive as
tristana's as impressive this all these
other people in Silicon Valley
she's at that level or more and and that
requires thinking so Tristan and I have
spent a lot of time trying to amplify
the signal from Shoshanna to make sure
more people are aware of them and you
know the other people who circle around
this thing are all looking at reshawna
like oh my god how did
see this right because it's so complex
it's so nuanced and how the hell did we
miss it well the answer is it's these
guys there's a there's a famous
sociologist in America named BF Skinner
no longer alive but he had these this
notion of operant conditioning this
notion that you could manipulate
behavior of any species by changing the
conditions in which you held them but
the critical element that he always said
was you had to do the experiment in a
way that the subject was not aware of it
and Google in particular has been really
careful to conduct experiments and ways
were not aware can I give you a couple
examples fire away
so think about Google Maps now love
music love it used it just got a 2,000
mile road trip across America and used
it to get me from Dallas to Norfolk
Virginia via a number of major cities so
it was in my experience there
surface-level lifesaver
exactly everybody loves Google Maps
right yeah now let's think about the
person who's drive in the morning to
work is an hour long or 45 minutes and
where there's more than one way to get
there there's a standard way that is the
you know all else being equal it's the
fastest way to go
you take that route every day but you
check every morning just to be sure and
every once in a while it'll say nope not
today today you're gonna take this
really weird route and maybe they say
there's traffic conditions or whatever
do you know what's really going on
there's a concept there's a concept in
engineering called load balancing which
is when you have a complex system in
order to have maximum efficiency through
the system you need to balance the load
and you distribute the weight or the
traffic in ways they keep everything
moving smoothly the same concept applies
in airplane it's why sometimes you have
to have put more people at the back of
the plane to keep the balance right so
when it comes to traffic the reality of
this thing is that on any given day some
people have to go on inferior
routes in order to maintain the flow of
the system as a whole which means that
sometimes when they tell you to take
that other route it's not because
there's a traffic problem it's because
hey it's your turn today you're gonna
take the inferior let's say you're in a
huge hurry that could be a real problem
for you and you've had no choice in it
because you trust Google and they've not
been honest with you about hey today is
your day they're just saying to you
please take this other route and you say
to yourself hey what's the big deal on
that and I'm going maybe there isn't one
right so then you think about how they
monetize maps or especially how they
monetize ways right so Waze is now that
it's the equivalent way his wages
owned by Google of course it's owned by
Google and and so ways you know it's
taking all the traffic conditions for
everybody
and putting in there and again the goal
of the person using maps or ways is to
get from one place to another as quickly
as possible but Google's goals are
actually different than that because
their load balancing in the case of maps
and in the case of both maps and ways
they gotta get paid now how do they get
paid
they get paid for something that you're
shana describes as footfall and football
is getting you to go buy some basically
advertisers pay them for traffic to go
buy their location so let's say they
know that you like fried chicken and
you're on ways and it's roughly meal
time well they're gonna drive you past
the fried chicken people who paid them
for football and that may take you off
the optimal route now does this happen
to every time no does it happen to you
some of them yes can it happen at a time
that's very unfortunate definitely but
here's what matters about Google is
playing God they're making choices for
you and because you trust them as an
honest broker it doesn't occur to you
that they don't have your best interests
at heart that they're really doing is
optimizing for their own business and on
those two it doesn't seem like it's that
big a deal now let's go to pokemons go
so most people don't realize where
Pokemon go came from in fact I didn't
know until Shoshanna told me so Google
had this thing remember those
Google glass yeah so Google glass was a
thing we had a little screen in the
corner so you could keep track of
whatever you were keeping track of all
the time and it had a camera pointing
for and as far as I can tell the reason
people were Google glass was so they
could look like a dork right remember do
you remember what we called them we
called the glass holes nice nice yes and
it completely failed but I want you
understand what Google was trying to do
they had been capturing human behavior
for a lot of ways and they've been
capturing a lot of free data right I
mean the reason they created Street View
was that they realized that having a
picture of every Street and having a
picture of every home was really
valuable and what Sun why is it valuable
well you'll see in a larger context they
want to know where everybody lives they
want to know what their place looks like
there are all kinds of ways at some
point you can monetize that information
you know for example you're not likely
to sell one of those little things that
take old people up staircases
you know those chairs that go on is that
lifts type thing yeah okay you're not
gonna do that to a one-story home right
so you know it's useful to have that
information but the point is they didn't
ask permission they start driving up
down the street they take a picture of
your home and whatever is in front of it
maybe your car maybe your kids whatever
your dog and they don't ask permission
but when you get to Google glass what
you're changing is you're going from a
static picture which is what street view
or satellite view is remember whether
you want it or not your home is in those
things ready for a burglar to now be
able to case your place without even
coming to look at and you have no choice
in no way to withdraw so now they want
it in real time with Google glass the
camera on the front is capturing the
behavior of the user and everyone around
them without their awareness and they
convert all that into data so if they if
I came up to you wearing Google glass
the camera would capture your face and
Google has all this incredible
artificial intelligence so they don't
just get a picture of you and ID who you
are they can look at the muscles in your
face and make a really good estimate of
your emotional state of mind you say so
for how they monetize that the
oh when you have enough data in a date
of hoodoo doll you can monetize anything
and so they captured that stuff but the
product failed they don't give up their
Google right they put it back in the lap
they reinvented this video game they
realize it's probably a bad idea to
publish it as Google so they called
something different
Niantic they spin it out that's a
separate company they call the game
pokemons go Nintendo licensed Pokemon to
them but Niantic the same guy who
created Street View created Niantic and
he is a you know like an apostle of BF
Skinner he's really big on operant
conditioning so pokey might go next
thing you know there's 1 billion people
wandering around with their phones
capturing video images of everything
that they see so what happens the people
think they're playing a game but Google
says or in Niantic says ah let's run a
few experiments in this post 9-11 world
can we put a Pokemon in somebody's
backyard and get you to knock on a
stranger's front door it turned out you
could I mean people would literally
descend on homes and knock on the door
so the experiment was unbelievable I
mean in America you can't get people
that not got a stranger's door for
anything other than pokemons go so how
about if we put it over a fence can we
get you to climb a fence people who had
never otherwise climb the fence climbed
a fence to chase a pokey so then they go
well let's commercialize it so they kind
of deal with Starbucks you know can we
get you to go into a Starbucks and buy a
coffee yes we can now the key thing to
understand is this is behavioral
manipulation and it's a billion people
they were doing it on simultaneously
people are terrified about what's going
on in China right China has a program
called Social Credit just designing is
behavioral manipulation to control the
whole population but get this there are
only 750 billion people with internet
access in China pokemons gone was a
wildly larger experiment than social
credit and you can see yourself well
it's harmless
and I'm going right but it's not the end
game now they have a project going on
Toronto Ontario called key site and it's
a smart city and they're taking
everything they learned from maps and
ways and Street View and Pokemon go and
plying it at city scale they call a
smart city but Google is going to gather
data from their sensors everywhere
there's no privacy right everything has
turned it into data all human experience
in that area and the things run into a
political problem because a small number
of people came up and said hang on how
do we influence this because Google had
said to the city that there could be no
interference for the people of Toronto
and what Google is doing in effect they
had to be protected from politics they
had to be protected from democracy that
they got to be in charge they got to
control the data do whatever they wanted
with it effectively they controlled the
public utilities they effectively
controlled all the city services inside
this development that they were going to
help fund and there would be no scrutiny
no control effectively they would be
substituting algorithms and artificial
intelligence for democracy now there's a
one-year hold on that project while the
city actually finally does the
deliberation while they have the
democratic process to decide if this is
good my simple observation here is that
these guys have a plan and it's again
it's not evil it's just a different
value system and I believe we're
supposed to have serious conversations
we're supposed to do the thought
experiments to imagine what it would be
like to live in something that looked
like the matrix or like Minority Report
it was run by a corporation something
over which we have no control that might
not even be in the same country where
I'm sure that for each of the elements
of business that you've put forward
today Google acting as whichever company
it may be whether it be ways or Pokemon
go or Facebook acting as Instagram or
however they piece it together they will
have a justification for why Street View
exists well it allows you to see things
before you get there or it allows you to
be more accurate with maps or the reason
why they redirect you well there
actually really was traffic what is the
evidence showing this other side have
there been whistleblowers inside of the
company which you've come out to be
clear Chris I mean your the points
you're making a demonstrable true there
is massive value from products like the
maps there's massive value from ways I'm
not saying you're not supposed to like
the products I don't my simple point
here is that Google's goals are at odds
with the goals of the people using the
products and the people using the
products just aren't aware of that
mm-hmm
my question is how do we know that the
primary directive that primary goal is
collect data well hang on to be clear it
doesn't have to be murder in the first
degree
it could be manslaughter right their
goals can be perfectly honorable and
still cause huge harm and that requires
some kind of action by society I believe
that their goals are honorable I just
disagree with the value system that
they're applying and my point to you
here is I mean I've said this I think
three times already
I believe these people are not bad
people
but I do think they have a different
philosophy and in the United States they
have they have grown up as executives in
an environment where we allowed the
banking industry to destroy the economy
with no negative consequences where we
allowed a bank Wells Fargo to take money
out of millions of accounts of consumers
with no penalties where we essentially
allow businesses to do whatever they
want with no constraints so against that
backdrop
smart people are going to take any
advantage they can get and these guys
are operating in a new area where there
are literally no rules and you know in
the early days of the telephone system
operators listened in to phone calls
eventually we decided you know that's
not a good idea we don't want the postal
service to be reading the mail we don't
want like operators listen to you we are
at exactly that point with Internet
platforms where we need to set the
boundaries and my only goal here is not
to convince you that there's something
wrong with Google or something wrong
with Facebook or something wrong with
anybody else but rather to say we need
to decide where the boundaries are in
the United States we have a problem
right now which we've had for a long
time that's gotten a lot worse which is
that we have a white supremacist who are
going on murderous rampages
all over the country with staggering
frequency more than one mass murder a
day nationwide and a huge percentage of
these are effectively incubated that is
the people are activated by things they
read things that they learn and interact
with on social media social media is
playing a an outsized role in a whole
series of problems related to public
health for children and adults for
democracy for privacy and our ability to
make choices without fear and for
competition and innovation and in that
sense I would argue that Google Facebook
Microsoft and Amazon are like the
chemical industry in the period between
1950 and 1980 when that industry was
very high growth very high profit why
because they could pour their waste
products mercury chromium mine tailings
wherever they felt like they could pour
mercury into fresh water polluting
rivers and streams and drinking water
they could leave mine tailings on the
side of the hill to leech into fresh
water
in rural areas and there were no cost no
consequences and eventually society
realized that was a terrible idea and we
should make the people who created these
toxic chemical spills pay the cost of
cleaning them up that is the
conversation we need to have if your
system is used to undermine democracy if
your system is used in ways that lead to
increases in teen suicide massive
increases in point if your system is
used in ways that allow disaffected
people to find each other
gather and then perpetrate violent crime
should there be some penalty should
there be some limit should there be
responsibility and Michael here is to
just trigger that conversation we looked
at these things as though they're all
separate problems that the public health
issue you know which would be Tristan's
brain hacking and all that was unrelated
to elections and that that was unrelated
to privacy and that was unrelated to the
whole issue of innovation competition
but in fact all of them are the result
of the incentives of what Shoshanna
Zubov calls surveillance capitalism and
it is this business model where our
lives our digital existence is for sale
to anybody that they can know the most
intimate things about us and we have no
control I mean why is it legal for
Google or Microsoft or anyone else to
read our documents or to read our emails
for their economic benefit why is it
legal for a bank or a credit card
processing company just sell our most
intimate financial details to anybody
who wants why is it legitimate for a
mobile company to sell our location why
is it legitimate for a healthcare
services company of any kind or
healthcare data company just most
intimate health data why is anything
about us
for sale that is a conversation I want
to have and again you don't have to
agree with me but we should have the
conversation and until we have the
conversation in the United States people
are going to be killed in shopping
centers at bars and in other
environments and schools and you know in
the United Kingdom you're gonna be
struggling with issues like brexit in
Myanmar they're gonna be dealing with a
genocide and the Philippines they're
gonna be dealing with death squads in
New Zealand they're gonna be dealing
with terrorist attacks on mas you know I
mean these are not small issues and the
critical thing is you know I talk to
young people all the time to see Roger
I'm a digital native I grew up with this
I'm not worried about this and I go I'm
not talking about how it affects you I'm
talking about how the data they get from
you is he used to harm other people
think about this Google has so much data
what they do is they identify life
events and then look at the things that
preceded it so if you buy they look at
everybody who buys a car and they look
at like a thousand or ten thousand steps
they took before they bought the car and
then compared it to everybody else right
and they find the distinct patterns they
do the same thing with women who
announced it that they're pregnant so
they look at like 10,000 steps in front
of that and they find what's common so
there are certain things before you buy
a car that you do that you may not even
be conscious of that don't say you're
buying a carpet or just a negative of
increasing probability because would you
have a date of voodoo doll you're not
selling targeting you're selling a
certainty right you're selling this I
have 90 percent confidence this person
was gonna buy a car or get this Google
knows I believe with 90 percent
confidence that a woman is pregnant
before she knows think about that for a
minute I'd like all the women were
loosing this to think about that from
you may not know if you're pregnant but
Google may and we ought to ask is that
okay because what happens is that once
they know everything in your feet
everything in your search results
reflects what they know that you do not
know and suddenly you do not as Tristan
says you do not have agency over your
life and I don't know that that's
legitimate there's a good point there I
recently made a comment on a podcast
about how much I love the new schedule
send email feature on Gmail I said it
this now allows you to send an email
tomorrow at 12:00 midday as opposed to
having to be online so it saves it any
dress and then publishes it when you
want but you are right if I start
writing to my business partner about
flyers for freshers events in September
which we need to get Flyers for in the
sidebar of that email I have adverts for
flyers great because they are allowed to
read the content of my emails and the
question of well actually they have
asserted the right to do that we've
never actually had a conversation
whether that's legit or not because
remember they say they're a common
carrier that's how they protect
themselves one legal area please that's
it isn't when they say they're a
platform not a media company to avoid
responsibility for the content on their
platforms they say we're a platform
which in in the parlance of the
communications industry it means that
you control a pipe and if you control a
pipe you're not responsible for it goes
through the pipe unless you know what it
is right if you're going through and
looking at it okay yep so essentially
this is what makes it illegal for the
Postal Service to read your letters for
fet what's pressed to look inside your
packages and for the phone company to
listen right and so you could say that
googles and Facebooks insistence that
they are platforms not media come is
therefore not responsible that that
means that they should not be allowed as
a precedent oh yeah
a lot of present point is in the United
States our congresses I think you could
say charitably ineffective and at the
moment the government the United Kingdom
is distracted right and as a consequence
getting thoughtful legislation to deal
with problems like this is harder than
it should be given the scale of the
problem right and my point to you is you
might find it incredibly convenient to
have a list of people who will sell you
flyers but there are points in your life
that should be private there are moments
when sanctuary is absolutely essential
to our psychological and human
well-being and these guys are
systematically stripping that away think
about Alexa you put a LexA in your
bedroom you put a LexA in your office
and you're trusting the employees of
Amazon you're trusting the hardware
vendor you're trusting hackers to never
do anything that hurts you and maybe
statistically you're gonna be okay but
they're gonna be a lot of people who are
harmed really badly from just the
indiscretions and the things that should
remain private and are not under this
model and Shoshanna Zubov makes this
brilliant point that the imperative of
surveillance campaigns is to invade
every possible domain of human existence
I mean when you hear about facebook
doing experiments to try to create
things that allow you to think instead
of typing your queries or your poses
they're trying to invade your head and
you say to yourself well it'll never
work and I go well I hope not but but
what if it does these are really smart
people right and the critical thing is
at a point in time when we're dealing
with climate change at a point in time
when we're dealing with crisis of
obesity and all of those stuff the best
and brightest
our economy are devoting a hundred
percent of their effort to manipulating
human attention and human behavior now
that sounds very Chinese to me right in
China the government is determined to
manipulate everybody in order to keep
them in line and I'm going well I just
think the United States of America and I
don't know how you feel in the United
Kingdom but but in the Unites States of
America I think that's a very unamerican
thing and our companies are doing it and
we are not conscious of it and I just
think there is something wrong with all
this happening outside of our awareness
I think you're right one of the things
that I want to touch on I want to begin
to go back a little bit further to the
beginning of your story and talk about
talk about this journey from 2006 to
2016 and yes and find out you were with
Facebook through its in not its
inception but really its adolescence I
suppose and it's establishing itself in
something the the world so what did you
see during that period I'd also love to
hear the first time that you met mark
and what that situation was like as well
I'm sure that the listeners would be
fascinated and then it's a it's a funny
story so let me go there first and then
you can ask the rest of the question so
yes
so when I met mark he had just had his
22nd birthday Facebook was two years old
they had 9 million users all of whom
were University and high school students
in the United States who were acquired
to use their school email account so
effectively they had authenticated
identity for every user of Facebook I
thought that was the game changer that
that meant Facebook would finally crack
the code a social media that had eluded
MySpace and Friendster in America online
and all the early efforts to to bring
people together on life I was convinced
that anonymity allowed bad actors to
pollute any environment they could get
into and that all of these things had
from the beginning whenever you allowed
anonymity it always does
into a into an ugly mess and so I I had
not used Facebook when I met Marcus I
was 50 years old and I didn't have an
authenticated school email address and
so I was convinced of this without
actually having used the product that's
conceptual I thought he'd solved the
core problem and one of his colleagues
sent me an email saying my boss has a
crisis and he needs to talk to somebody
he's been around a long time it really
gets the valley who can help him figure
now would she take a meeting and so mark
comes to my office and you know he
looked just like Mark Zuckerberg
he's got the sandals he's got the skinny
jeans the great t-shirt the hoodie the
courier bag short curly hair he sits
down I said that no keep in mind I'm in
business with a rock star right Bono
where we're investing at the
intersection of technology and media and
we have one conference room that's set
up like a living room with video game
consoles and stereos and it's soundproof
doing the insurance like it looks like a
living room right I mean it's big comfy
chairs we're three feet apart in these
two comfy chairs that's a mark before
you say a word would you mind if I gave
you the context for why I'm taking this
meeting because once you start talking
you'll assume anything I say is
influenced by what you've already told
it so I need to say something before you
say he said going go ahead
I said look mark you know you've had
nine million in revenues you got nine
million users but I think you have the
most important company since Google and
before long you will be bigger than
Google is today and because of that if
it hasn't already happened either
Microsoft or Yahoo it's gonna come up to
you and offer you 1 billion dollars to
buy Facebook they're gonna do it right
now
and everybody you know your mom and dad
your board of directors your management
team employees your friends everything
mark take the money it's a billion
dollars dude you're 22 you can change
the world you have 650 million bucks
your venture capital still promised to
back your next company and he'll tell
you it'll be way better than Facebook
said mark I've been doing this for 24
years and I know two things
with extremely high confidence one is
there is not one entrepreneur in Silicon
Valley who has ever had the perfect idea
at the perfect time twice I am convinced
Facebook is the perfect idea at the
perfect time it didn't happen for Steve
Jobs that could happen for you the
second thing I don't care who buys
they're gonna wreck it this is your baby
if you believe in the vision you got to
carry it out so you have to imagine
we're three feet apart on comfy chairs
in this conference room with mood
lighting right it's not like it's not
like a conference it's not like a
conference room it's really at like a
living room with low lighting and we're
right next to each other face to face
I'm expected I've just laid this really
heavy trip on a guy I've never met he's
22 right some kind of reaction I'm
expecting I got nothing I mean he goes
into these this series of thinker poses
he's trying to decide if he trusts me
and I don't know if you've ever sat with
somebody in an absolutely dead quiet
room expecting a response mm-hmm and not
gotten one right in 15 seconds it starts
to get really really uncommon in a
lifetime yeah right at the one-minute
mark I'm saying to myself well it's okay
cuz he's really showing me great respect
he's trying to decide if he trusts me at
the two-minute mark I'm going well this
is really creepy at three minutes I'm
digging trenches in the upholstery of
the chair I'm sitting it at four minutes
I'm ready to scream but I realize I'm in
the presence of a singularity right I
mean there's nothing like this has ever
happened to me in my life and I'm
thinking wow this kid is like he's truly
one-of-a-kind I mean I've never seen
anybody go through a thought process
like this
finally he calms down and he looks up
and he goes you're not gonna believe
this I go try me that story you just
told that's
here that exact thing has just happened
every detail that you said was correct
Yahoo billion dollars everybody told me
I saw the company and I said well mark
what do you want to do do you want to
sell he goes no but I can't run it by
myself and I don't want to disappoint
everybody and I said well hang on you
got plenty of capital you're growing
like a bat out of hell they don't have
any right to tell you the dance is over
so I helped him understand how you
convince people that wait a minute when
you're part of a rocket ship
you don't abort the mission just because
you think you've gone high enough right
you you play it out and the whole
meeting maybe took half an hour he goes
back he kills the deal can visit
everybody to do the right thing which
they did and from that point for three
years I was one of his advisors because
imagine this he's got a problem right
that his board of directors wanted to
sell the company's management he wants
the company he was gonna have to do some
upgrading and he didn't know who to
trust so I was one of the people he
trusted so I helped with that and the
key thing I did was to bring in Cheryl
and I knew Cheryl back from when she was
at the Treasury Department cuz she and
bono had worked together to forgive all
this debt of emerging countries for the
millennium and she introduced bono to me
and then I helped to introduce her to
Google which got her started in Silicon
Valley so we were super close and I
always convinced she was the right fit
for more and likewise mark for her so
you could imagine I'm a huge believer in
this company but around 2009 Cheryl's on
board in place and the thing about
really successful the executives of
Silicon Valley's they rotate their
mentors according to what they need and
by 2009 they had the management team
that they wanted so my role was kind of
done so I move into the background and
I'm in this I'm liking the bleachers
cheering a lot but I'm not no longer an
insider from 2009 what was your role
from 2009 what what did you do was it
just
so we were an investor so he it didn't
happen right away but about a year after
I met Marc he gave us a chance to invest
and then an another one that elevation
took advantage of default did you unload
every single penny of your net worth in
it into that to try and minimize no no I
mean it wasn't at all obvious at the
beginning what the business model was I
thought with the rocket ship propelling
itself towards the future as you suggest
yeah yeah yeah yeah but that's not I
mean elevation made a huge investment
okay it made us big investments that
could and it worked great for elevation
and you know but to be clear it doesn't
work quite the way you describe that's
just not how the world works and and
again I I really liked it I liked Marc I
like to share a lot I was a real big
believer now the thing is I'm a
professional technology analyst and
there were signals along the way that
not everything was right but unlike
Google Facebook took quite a long time
to get its business model right and the
thing that's a problem today does didn't
really begin until about 2013 so I've
been out of the company 40 years by the
time it began but the things that led to
it and the things that caused a problem
there were signs as early as 2007 really
that that mark did not respect the
people who use the products that he
didn't respect privacy and that he
wanted to push them force them if
necessary into a level of openness that
would ultimately be really problematic
can you remember the first particular
signal of that kind that that comes to
mind or whether it's couple of those
that come to mold the problem here was
that I thought that he learned from the
mistakes the first one was a thing
called beacon and you may remember pika
beacon was their first effort at
monetization at scale and the notion was
if you were out in the real world and
you bought something and you were a
Facebook user
the person you bought it from could do a
promotion on Facebook and publish it to
your newsfeed you know you went to a
sporting goods store and bought trainers
right and they published in unity but
almost immediately a disaster happened a
young American man bought an engagement
ring from an online company called
overstock.com an overstock wasn't one of
those things that take sold things that
really deep discounts so they published
with news feed that mr. X has just
bought an engagement ring for ninety
five percent off and here's a picture of
him so the first word his bride-to-be
gets that he's going to propose is that
she sees the scene as new scene all
these friends need this thing at the
same time now nobody has any control
they have no idea this is going on it's
just started and it's a massive disaster
and I mean it we're talking train wreck
of the first work and it's the kind of
thing where you would think a company
would never go near invasions of privacy
again and I want to say that's sort of
2007 that that's going on and so Sheryl
comes in in early 2008
you know they repackage the technology
of something called Facebook Connect
which it works the same way but it does
something totally different Facebook
Connect is a very convenient way to log
on to a website so you know after number
lots of passwords the problem is of
course a Facebook used yet to spy on
people as they went around the lamp the
same way that when they put light
buttons around the web was all about
tracking what you were doing is you went
around the web now if Facebook resisted
using that data in their advertising for
a long time but when they went public
the press that the ad tool they had at
the time was incredibly successful
because of the growth in users
advertisers have to go where the
audience is and so they were putting
lots of ads on but Facebook were priced
the ads and so all the advertisers were
anger and Facebook didn't want to cut
the prices they want to make the ads
more valuable so they realized they had
to take what they would call web data
you know from spying on you as you go
around the web tracking and embed that
into the ad system which they did
beginning in 2013 and that was the
trigger for all the bad stuff to happen
the problem was that it wasn't obvious
that that it would have the negative
consequences for elections or for public
health or for privacy you know at the
beginning it just appeared as though you
know you were getting ads that were
better targeted right they seemed way
more relevant to you and that you can
log into a new e-commerce website by
saying sign up with Facebook as opposed
to having to put you credentials in and
you could like something out on the web
and it would show up in your Facebook
feed you know I'm saying all these
things seem very innocent and convenient
but what we didn't think about was it
literally anybody could use them which
means that you know in Tahrir Square
you've got a protest organized in Egypt
over Facebook and then crushed over
Facebook because the forces of darkness
if you will had way more money way more
power and every bit is easy access to
Facebook as the protesters have and so
they were able to use all these tools to
identify who the protesters were ramming
his facebook basically in those days you
know they had this thing when they were
first trying to figure out monetization
all they had was a large user count but
people spent like a minute a day and
then this company called Zynga came
along with a poker game and with
farmville and where people were spending
an hour a day playing farmville are
playing poker and what Zynga did that
was so clever was they kind of hacked
the Facebook system to get friends and
Facebook realize wow we give app
developers access to friends lists they
could build these social apps and
that'll make usage go way way up so
beginning in 2009 or so they started so
tonight we're doing the US Federal Trade
Commission going wait a minute you have
to get permission from the users before
you do that face because okay no problem
we'll sign a consent screen promise to
do that which they completely ignore so
they continue to give it access and
here's the math they went public in 2012
they had nine million apps in theory all
of them were eligible to get these
friends lists but let's just imagine
only 1% did I believe that number was
actually hired that lets imagine alone
1% did that would be 90,000 apps let's
think about what some of those apps were
well how about Xbox Live you know how
about PlayStation right I mean these are
things with tens or hundreds of millions
of users getting access to the friends
list of all of those users on Facebook
that's everybody on Facebook multiple
times over right so everybody stays
that's the thing that Cambridge
analytical was about that actual thing
and that took place after the consent
decree and that's where the Federal
Trade Commission just put a five billion
dollar penalty out which by the way was
a bargain the reality is they probably
if if you have applied normal Federal
Trade Commission pricing to the each
violation it was probably multiple
trillion dollars worth of violations I
mean as digital toxic spills go it's
hard to get hard to imagine anything
bigger than that
but the digital toxic spill associated
with things like video game platforms
was almost certainly orders of magnitude
larger and five million is just the cost
of businesses other it's way way way too
low and it didn't mean anything to go
investors thought it was literally less
than a slap on the wrist I mean the
festers treated it like they'd just been
handed a bouquet of roses by the Federal
Trade Commission tell us terrible and
the point here is I'm an analyst I might
have picked up signals earlier and the
embarrassing thing was I retired at the
end of 2015 and I retired because the
culture of Silicon Valley changed if you
think about it I grew up in the era
Steve Jobs and
you know Gordon born this notion of
using technology to empower the people
who use it it had the combination of the
intersection of the value system the
u.s. space program with the hippy value
systems of empowerment and we all
believed in it and that began to change
after 2000 and I didn't initially
appreciate how profound the change was
but it was really led by what are now
known as the PayPal mafia which is Peter
Thiel and Ilan Moscone and Reid Hoffman
and the rest found a PayPal who were not
just brilliant executives but brilliant
investors and had a set of insights
about how the technology world was
evolving that they saw before anybody
else and they took advantage of before
everybody else in it really was what
created social media so they did
LinkedIn and Facebook and a bunch of
other stuff and but they brought a
different value system they brought this
hyper libertarian value system wealth
hey move fast break things right that
you're not responding you could disrupt
without being responsible for the
consequences of your actions and that
unfortunately happened in kind of a
vacuum that post the bubble bursting
into thousands of intricate industry was
in retreat it turned out that that was a
critical moment because suddenly you
could you know the the limitations
historically of technology we didn't
have enough processing power or memory
or storage or bandwidth to do what you
wanted to do those all basically
evaporated around 2003 2004 so you could
for the first time do global consumer
product like Facebook or Google or or
Instagram and these guys thought for
anybody else so they got there and they
set the rules and they set the culture
and at the beginning it was like this
hybrid culture right where these people
were doing real business and more or
less abating the rules but the second
generation companies so now we're
talking about YouTube we're talking
about uber and lyft and Spotify we're
talking about air B&B these guys
basically started off with the notion
that laws just don't
and that there are people out there who
do not understand what's going on and we
can take advantage of them because we're
not responsible for life so suddenly
predatory business models become the
rule in Silicon Valley you know there's
a company and the nicotine business
called jewel that makes vape pants and
every one of these things I had a chance
to invest in and I'm just sitting there
going wait a minute this is the best
that Silicon Valley has to offer I can't
manage other people's money if I'm not
willing to invest in these things but my
personal value system allow me to go
there and so I realized I got retired so
I retire in 2015 at the very end because
elevation winds up very successfully we
distribute everything at the end of 2015
and I'm free free at last and something
happened because within a month I'm on
vacation with my month one my wife and
I'm looking at Facebook and I see posts
coming from Facebook groups notionally
associated with the Bernie Sanders for
president campaign this is very
beginning of the Democratic primary and
they're really deeply misogynistic and
they're not the sort of thing any
campaign would want his fingerprints on
you'd never put it on an official Bernie
site that you were doing misogynistic
thing and yet it was spreading like
wildfire like somebody was spending
money to get my friends to join these
Facebook groups I'm thinking that's
really weird and really bad you know cuz
I I know it's I I have a rock and roll
band called moon Ellis actually second
one called doobie Decimal System and
we've used Facebook really successfully
to build our fan base into the kids and
tell funds about when you've got shows
an event yes and communicate with them
directly and for them to communicate I
mean we have there's a Facebook group
for Facebook but there's one called the
tribe that's just the fans right and you
know it's so it's like you know I'm I
mean I've been a true believer Facebook
early adopter I mean we did the first
Facebook live of a rock and roll concert
the date the product was turned on we
had a show that night and we broadcast
the whole show on Facebook live
time that have been done that's cool ya
know and we did a bunch of stuff we were
the first one on on whatever the one is
the Twitter ons I can only remember the
name I know you mean yeah it's what
Scott Oh
periscope periscope but all those things
came out we missed meerkat by like four
days but but you know we we were really
early doctor and we've been streaming
our shows for years right so we really
knew a lot about it and I have four
patents on live streaming which by the
way are completely worthless because the
market power of Facebook and Google
I can't enforce them but the point here
is that in March of 2016
Facebook expelled a group that was using
the ad tools to identify people who are
interested in black lives matter which
is a protest group and a completely
peaceful honorable really in my opinion
important civil rights organization and
they were gathering data on they
identified any of these people and
selling it to police departments which
is a massive civil rights violation a
facebook did the right thing right they
expelled them but by then the damage had
been done and that's the first inkling I
got that wait a minute these ad tools
are not benign but brexit was the
critical thing because it brexit all of
a sudden I realized wait a minute there
is an asymmetry because engagement you
know you know Tristan's hypothesis right
you want to go down the brain stem so
the most basic human emotions fear and
outrage which are part of
flight-or-fight that those are the the
lowest common denominator you can get
engagement from the largest number of
people by appealing to that and it's
asymmetric basically people with a
naturally conservative personality will
be on average more fearful so from a
political perspective right it's easier
to use these tools to inflame people who
think of themselves as being
conservative which means you can't use
these tools equally effectively
across the full political spectrum
there's a massive asymmetry that's
interesting and that's something I've
never I've never heard of and that
asymmetry has been didn't begin here
that's been Rupert Murdoch's model from
the beginning right and so the Murdoch
organization has played to that on Fox
and on Sky and wherever they've had
control of the news agenda and you know
it's just these are elements of human
psychology and we can't afford and I
didn't know all the nuances but I knew
enough to do that there was something
really wrong here and that's when I got
you know activated to try to do
something but I begin in this context
I'm viewing Facebook is the victim when
I went to mark and Cheryl nine days
before the US election in 2016 it was as
a friend as their mentor to try to alert
them of something that was I thought
really horrible and the truth is I think
that they looked at me and said Roger if
you're so smart
where are your two billion active users
you know where are your billions of
dollars because for the prior five or
six years pretty much everything
Facebook had done had worked out and if
you're as successful as they were for as
long as they were human psychology you
start to think that all these things
happen cuz you're a genius and that
therefore everything you think is right
right they they've been proving critics
wrong for a long time and so I think
their visceral reaction was to just
assume I was wrong and I totally
understood that which is why I spent
three months trying to persuade him
because I mean I've been around this a
long time and this is not the first
group of people I've seen have had that
kind of Midas psychology and I didn't I
didn't think less of them because of it
right I just thought it was a high bar
to get over and I was worried that I was
no longer the right messenger and but I
spent three months I gave it my best
shot because I didn't want to say
anything publicly because I thought the
minute I said something publicly was
gonna change our relationship firm
so I didn't say any public for a long
time actually we did another six months
after that four I said anything publicly
and because I wanted to give them a
chance to get it right I was convinced
that no one could fix these problems
better than the people running the
companies and keep in mind at that point
I think it's just Facebook I have no
idea that this is also by the Instagram
it's also about Google it's also YouTube
it's about you know Microsoft Amazon all
these are the companies I just you know
maybe it's another to it to interject
there what I think a lot of people at
home might be thinking and certainly one
of the thoughts that's coming through in
my mind is that it looks to me and it
seems to me like right now litigating
from top down restricting what platforms
can do or some sort of very stringent
law enforcement with more transparency
etc etc appears to be really one of the
few cards that we have to play now but
as you've alluded to they're a much more
effective solution would have been for
it to be bottoms up
would have been for the people within
the business behind the business to have
gotten their nipped it in the bud early
and then redirected the business model
appropriately well we continue to appeal
to employees at all these companies
interest on does this every week and
he's still in communications with senior
people at at particularly Facebook and
Twitter now the reason we do that
you may remember Ober had a massive
situation where the woman came named
Susan Fowler and Susan wrote a blog post
a couple years ago in which she talked
about the toxic culture at at uber and
here's the thing the toxic culture of
uber wasn't a secret everybody knew
about it but the management team the
board of directors the employees
tolerated it because the company was on
this rocket ship of growth and Susan
Fowler wrote this blog post that for
whatever reason
shifted the perception of the employees
so dramatically that over the next six
months there was almost a hundred
percent turnover of the management team
it changed everything
and we looked at that way that's all we
need here we just need to get the right
person and it was intricate so the
serious people first Justin Rosenstein
who did the like button then Sean Parker
we'd been the first president and
Facebook completely ignores these guys
and then Chamath Paul Hypatia who had
been in charge of growth until 2011 does
a thing at Stanford University in late
November of 2017 and it gets publicized
in early December and we're going this
is it
samatha had hired essentially all the
people running the growth team which is
the brain hacking part of Facebook and
we're thinking this is the guy well
Facebook apparently recognized that and
they came down on him and somehow within
72 hours he reverses his field
completely it starts becoming a
spokesman for Facebook and he goes on TV
he came to the UK he was on Kristiana
month or and CNN and and he's talking
about how you know sucks the smartest
guy on earth and all he Suk can fix
everything in society and I mean not
quite but something like that and I'm
looking at that going wow
I mean Jamaat Father Bhatia is a
world-class poker player
I mean seriously he finished like
hundred first out of I want to say 3500
players in the world chip poker
championship I mean he is no shrinking
by the notion I mean he's not gonna roll
over cuz Cheryl calls up and yells at
him right that's just he's not that man
what do you think I haven't I have no
idea I mean there's been a lot of
speculation I only mention moth one time
doc asked me to help recruit him when he
went into Facebook because his office
was literally directly upstairs from
buying a television and so I spent an
hour and a half and I will take Massimo
the smartest
I've ever met one of the most ambitious
people I've ever met he's he's almost
the prototypical top of the pyramid
Silicon Valley bro mmm exactly the kind
of person you would want running the
growth day growth the growth team at
Facebook I mean this luck totally picked
the right guy
and you know so I don't know him well
enough to know what really drove it but
you know there but you know you can
speculate but it doesn't the point is it
doesn't matter they turned him around
and ever since with all that news flow
there hasn't been anybody else other
than Chris Hughes the co-founder who's
really come out and said anything that
chris has been amazingly effective if he
was Mark's roommate in college he was
the fourth co-founder of Facebook and he
has been talking a lot about any trust
and I have enormous respect for Chris
but think about this according to mates
no phones yeah there been at least 9,000
people killed in what the UN calls in
classic ethnic cleansing in Myanmar
there are I think 42,000 missing and
presumed dead so if they're all dead
let's assume that's 51,000 people
not one person at Facebook has spoken
out saying this is a moral outrage and
we need to do something that's now won
and I'm thinking myself how can that be
I mean how can it be and what after
Christchurch
I mean Christchurch proportion to the
population New Zealand Christchurch is
exactly the same percentage that 9/11
was in the u.s. right I mean this is a
nationally traumatizing event and nobody
it's got a problem with that I'm just
going hang on what is going on here you
know how about YouTube right I mean
YouTube recruits and trains terrorists
it poisons the minds of little children
and it's caused in the United States an
epidemic of measles it's got you know
climate change denial happens on YouTube
flat earth happens on YouTube I mean
there's been one
Guillaume cello was a algorithms
engineer left the company and has become
an activist but no current employees
have got a problem with this actually
they do they spoke out quietly in the
company ignore them
right and that's the difference between
Google and Facebook is a Google you've
seen the employees go to management and
tell them there was something wrong with
YouTube they fought against maven which
was a defense contract they protest at
least a little bit against creating
dragonfly which was the version of the
search engine for China with all the
censoring and then they had a very well
at least temporarily successful protest
against the required arbitration in
cases of sexual harassment sexual
misconduct but Google's punished the
people who organized the protest and
they've gotten away with that but at
least at Google you see signs of the
employees sticking their heads up and
doing something and that makes me
hopeful but Google's a really smart
company really well managed a lot of
tentacles in a lot of places and they're
the ones who are you know trying to
replace cities Facebook's just trying to
replace currencies which is a disastrous
right because you sit there you go hang
on what makes you a sovereign nature
could the legitimate use of force with
the military in the police and control a
currency and Facebook's go hey we're
gonna replace you on the currency part
and I'm like WTF dudes I mean come on
what do you think it that's enough
so to round up one of the things that I
think a lot of people want to know and
me myself yeah it's fine that's fine
oh it's 116 but they blow it again don't
worry I love doing a pre record it just
means that we can we can do whatever we
want I've got about exactly three
minutes if that's okay I'm just gonna
add it one of the things I'm thinking
I'm sure a lot of people at home will be
as well is that we are currently a part
of this infrastructure
a lot of these things are part of our
lives totally
are there any bits of advice is there
anything which you can suggest to the
people at home which are the lesser of
few evils should I actually no actually
there there are positive things going on
okay the most important thing to
understand is that Apple has decided to
make protecting consumer privacy the
focus of their product development the
focus of their business and the things
that they've done are huge and they're
getting more huge by the day so you know
if you do facial recognition an apple
that image of you which is incredibly
detailed never leaves the phone that's a
huge deal Siri one of the reasons why
Syria doesn't perform as well as Alexa
is they do a huge amount of the
processing on the phone can minimize the
data that goes into the system Apple
Maps Apple spends a billion dollars a
year on this mapping product they do not
know monetization knowledge you know why
it exists so that you don't have to use
Google Maps and here's what's really
interesting instead of doing that Google
does which is to track every route you
ever take forever Apple as soon as
you're done with the route snips off the
depot
place you left from in the place you're
going to brakes the rest of the ten
segments and anonymizes them so they
can't reconstruct your route so then
Apple creates Apple pay where you can
use your phone to pay for stuff the
merchants all they get is money it's
like you've just done a cash transaction
but the data leakage occurs with your
credit card particular if you're on
MasterCard it there's less data a little
bit less data linkage with well the data
leakage on Verizon occurs in a different
place but Apple says okay so we're gonna
make a credit card and the deal and this
is the guy with the bank we partnered
with can't leak any of the data so if
you use an Apple card which comes out
this month in the United States and soon
thereafter everywhere else if you get an
Apple card and you use Apple pay an
apple cart it is like paying cash it is
a great idea Apple has a new thing
coming out in the new operating system
called sign-in with Apple that's the
equivalent of Facebook Connect or Google
connect but the differences it is this a
random email every time you log on to a
website so they can't track you now this
is
important stuff because basically Apple
is going after a portion of surveillance
capitalism and they're going after it
hard and in a way anybody can use the
other thing that's going on around Apple
is that they're all these other products
and this is like DuckDuckGo for search
but also now for browsing disconnect me
which blocks trackers from being sent
out by apps that are running inside your
phone I mean the Apple ecosystem is
becoming wildly more secure where
Android the whole purpose of Android is
surveillance so the first thing is if
you've got an Android as soon as your
contract is done okay seriously that is
the best thing you can do I don't I
don't think you have to drop you know
using the apps you love but what I would
recommend you do is don't embrace
ecosystems all the way in right if
you're gonna use Facebook don't use
messenger don't use everything with
Google and the Google accounts do things
anonymously right if you must use Google
products now I've been playing I treat
Google like a game remember Frogger yep
I'd see Google like Frogger I'm the Frog
Google sir River the logs of the other
products like the Apple products or
DuckDuckGo or disconnect me and and my
goal is to avoid Houston Cougars an
economist I'm a musician and the wave
musicians share music if they say if you
got a learner so I'm that was created by
somebody else you listen to it on
YouTube right so I have a real problem
with YouTube but I haven't I haven't
done a Google search in two years I
haven't used Google Docs in over a year
and but there's some things that you
know this morning somebody called me and
they want us to do a conference call on
Google Hangouts I got no why can I do
that you got to call me yes and my point
here is I made it into a game and I
can't really win the game I can just
stay alive a little bit longer I pay
cash for a lot of stuff now you say
Roger you're paranoid I go die that I
readily admit that but my point is I'm
mostly doing it to see if it could be
done right yeah again it's a thought
experiment yeah you're supposed to ask
the question what if I'm right and
the most important thing is every piece
of evidence I track every new story that
goes by I get hundreds per month these
guys haven't learned a thing
I mean the ad stuff that they were
supposedly going to protect in the
context of Elections does not work right
that you know you see in the UK there's
this brand new story about Boris Johnson
and you know that's that that
consultancy that did basically
propaganda on behalf of Yeltsin or on
behalf of Boris Johnson that was you
know it was authentic because the people
put their real names on it but you
couldn't connect it to Johnson and you
know it basically went through a
loophole in the new rules I mean there
is no protection for democracy right now
and obviously Google still trying to
push it smart cities and Amazon's going
in there and taking over the health care
industry and Microsoft's playing all
these games in AI and we don't yet have
enough pressure and so I'm just saying
to people look meet when you meet a
politician get in their face and go when
are you going to look out for my privacy
when are you gonna look out for my
self-interest because there is no reason
that you can't have all the service you
should love on the internet without
surveillance stick surveillance
capitalism the surveillance is there
only for the benefit of the vendors of
the platforms and the services we love
god bless I mean I'm not what I want to
do I want the next big thing to be a
return to technology that empowers us
and that's a way bigger opportunity why
do we want to only work for four
companies in the whole world it'd be
much better to have an environment where
you can start a company in your living
room or in your basement and be an
entrepreneur your own thing and right
now that's getting harder and harder to
do and we don't have to be that way we
can go back to the value system that
Steve Jobs called bicycles for the like
technology that helps us be more fit as
well as being more fun
Roger it's been fascinating today a lot
to think about
especially with David Carroll's episode
if you have not already checked that out
I suggest that you go and have a look
also
what would you suggest if people want to
read a little bit more is the one blog
is that one Twitter account is there one
particular webpage that you would direct
them to I I wish there were the most
important thing if you have the courage
is to read or listen to the audiobook of
the age of surveillance capitalism by
Shoshanna Zubov failing that the best
journalists in the United States on this
issue is Kara Swisher she does a month
actually now I guess a biweekly column
in The New York Times so Kara Swisher
his Twitter account is a really good one
to follow I think David Carroll's
Twitter accounts excellent fall a Carol
Cadwallader and the UK relative to
anything that was you know privacy but
brexit and and and Cambridge
analytically she's absolutely the best
but it's a moment they're not enough of
us in the advocacy world to create a
central hub for all this God knows I'm I
mean I just don't have enough time today
and so what I would tell you here is it
does take a little bit of energy but
that's okay because there you know
there's only a million of them
the rest of us around the same team so
you can join you can join teeth human
and go for it okay I like it a lot Roger
I really appreciate your time thank you
so much
link to hooked on Amazon and I advise
you to go and check out he'll be on
audible as well right oh yeah it's on
audible and and you know the great thing
is I'm coming to the UK in September I'm
going to do a bunch of events in London
and you can go to book calm if you want
to see where I'm gonna be
and just the thing I would say to
everybody is again it's your life you
get to make your own choices well I want
to make sure that you get to make your
own choice okay and that's what this is
about
that's a great way to finish Roger thank
you so much for your time guys and girls
who are listening if you are in the UK
and you want to meet Roger don't forget
to go and check out the website it will
be linked in the show notes below along
with everything else please do not
forget to Like share subscribe to all
that good stuff
Roger I hope you have a great time and I
really hope that you enjoy your trip to
the UK as well I hope I would get to see
each other Chris take a fantastic
[Music]
you